il se passe de drôles de choses dans le
château d'azay-le-rideau dès l'entrée
les enfants les enquêteurs sont
accueillis par la reine marguerite de
valois et figure toi que j'ai prêté mes
bijoux d'autres des très jolies à ma
copine antoinette qui habitent ici au
château d'azay et on lui a volé les
bijoux les enfants vont aller à la
rencontre des autres personnages sont
dans le château moi j'ai le plus gros
problème on m'a piqué mes bijoux certes
mais les quatre potentiels coupables
sont dans le château et il faut que les
enfants et les interrogeaient beaucoup
plus motivés que de suivre un guide les
enfants ce picto jeu
jusqu'en
1883 il venait votre requête dans les
arts
dans les combles y croise jeanne la
suivante de madame raffin les détectives
note l'important n'est pas l'orthographe
mais bien trouver le coupable la
cuisinière elle m'a dit avoir vu rôder
dimanche au tantôt un homme près de la
chambre de madame et ça ce n'est pas un
hasard mais elle n'a pas eu le temps de
reconnaître son visage
qu'elle a dit que vaille avait que
naviguer traces ne pas vous et que
quelqu'un des yeux un homme sur le
palier de la chambre renaissance trouvé
ni celle du prénom du personnage que
vous allez maintenant rencontre à la
chambre renaissance
théâtralisée ludique toute la famille
s'amuse et réfléchi guy de st-gelais de
lansac le propriétaire oui tout à fait
il marie d'antoinette que vous verrez la
scène si rose lorsque j'ai ouvert mon
coffre à bijoux d'été vide au château
d'azay-le-rideau le week-end et les
vacances de la toussaint s'annonce bien
nous sommes très heureux de voir que le
public est au rendez-vous et même au
delà de nos attentes on a fait une belle
belle saison estivale et donc cette
tendance se confirme sur les vacances de
la toussaint ce qui est une très bonne
nouvelle près du miroir d'eau sur le
chemin de la chapelle épilogue de
l'enquète on croise des enfants et des
parents seront bien les châteaux comme
ça des jeux
désignant ça fait sortir les filles
c'est très bien puis en même temps il ya
une visite culturelle il fait beau donc
c'est super une fois le mystère des
bijoux résolu les familles profitent de
l'extérieur sous le soleil le parc a
revêtu ses habits d'automne le décor est
somptueux